Anne Hathaway's stunning in G Vaughn she
at the serenity premiere in New York
City the train but this is something I
would wear I feel like a person and
normally you feel like some I don't know
all of these things but can be enjoyable
too but I feel I feel a little more
grounded I want you to take them out on
your boat and drop them in the ocean for
the Sharks the actor has spoke to et
about what it was like filming her
upcoming drama on an island in the
Indian Ocean
[Music]
like you know we're very lucky to get to
do the work but it was it was emotional
and painful and heavy work
I just loved being with a group of
committed artists you know me you know
me I'm a nerd
so I just loved that aspect of it being
with people who all believed in the
sanatorium we're willing to go out and
be out in the ocean for 12 hours at a
time and nobody complained and everybody
does that did the work together we had
to send it back since that's always
present
[Music]
you know I think they complement each
other
I always think New York is even better
when you leave and then keep you enjoy
it more when you get back path away also
opened up about her relationship with
her Devil Wears Prada co-star Emily
Blunt and what their 2008 Vanity Fair
Hollywood Issue cover meant for her
career when I was there with Jess and
Emily and
[Music]